مسار جده التفاوضيه بين طرفي الصراع في
السودان جرى على مرحلتين وقادته جهود
سعوديه امريكيه في السادس من مايو الماضي
انطلقت هذه المحادثات بين ممثلين عن الجيش
والدعم السريع اسبوع من المحادثات افضى
الى توقيع اعلان جده يتضمن التزاما بحمايه
المدنيين وبايصال المساعدات الانسانيه
وبانسحاب القوات من المستشفيات
عشر من مايو انطلقت جوله ثانيه من هذه
المفاوضات هدفها التوصل لوقف نهائي لاطلاق
النار مخرجات الجوله اعلنت في الحادي
والعشرين من مايو الماضي شملت هدنه لمده
سبعه ايام
في 29 من مايو مدد وقف اطلاق النار لمده
خمسه ايام في خطوه وصفت بانها تمهد
الاتفاق وقف اطلاق نار شامل وفي الحادي
والثلاثين من مايو علق الجيش السوداني
مشاركته في المفاوضات واتهم الدعم السريع
بعدم التزام بالبنود في الثاني من يونيو
الجاري اعلنت واشنطن والرياض تعليق
مباحثات جدا نتيجه الانتهاكات الجسيمه
المتكرره لوقف اطلاق النار قصير الامد وفق
تعبيرهما